[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK, folks.
Here we are again.
Welcome back for another episode
of theory of computation.
This is lecture number 3.
I'm going to review
what we've been doing.
We've been looking at finite
automata and regular languages.
Those are the languages that
finite automata can recognize.
And we talked about
nondeterminism.
So we had non-deterministic
finite automata
and deterministic
finite automata.
We showed that
they're equivalent.
We looked at the
closure properties
over the regular operations
union, concatenation, and star,
and showed that the regular
language is really--
the class of regular
languages is closed
under those regular operations.
And we used the
constructions that we
developed in the proof of
those closure properties
to show that the--
we can give a way to
convert regular expressions
to finite automata.
So that is-- was
partway toward our goal
of showing that these regular
expressions and finite automata
are equivalent with respect
to the class of languages
they describe, namely,
the regular languages.
So regular expressions
of finite automata
are interchangeable
from the perspective
of what kinds of languages
you can do with them.
So we're going to
finish that off today.
So let's take a look
at what our next topics
we're going to be covering.
We're going to reverse
the construction we
gave last time which allowed us
to convert regular expressions
to finite automata.
Now we're going to go backwards.
We're going to show how to
convert finite automata back
to regular expressions.
And that-- those two
constructions together
show us that the regular
expressions and finite automata
can be interconverted
from one another,
and they're therefore
equivalent with respect
to the kinds of things they
can do in language recognition
or generation.
Then, we're going
to prove that--
we're going to look at how you
prove certain languages are not
regular, they're
beyond the capabilities
of finite automata.
And finally, at the
end, we're going
to introduce a new model
of computation which
is more powerful than
the finite automata
and regular expressions, namely,
the context-free grammars.
Those can do other
kinds of languages
that the simpler finite automata
regular expressions models
can't do.
And I would also just like
to note that a lot of what
we're doing is a warm-up
toward the more powerful models
of computation that we're
going to be looking at later--
well, in a week or so--
which are more general
purpose computation.
But along the way, introducing
these models of finite automata
in context-free languages
is interesting and helpful
because many of those--
a number-- those models
turn out to be useful
in a number of applications,
whether it's from linguistics
to programming languages.
And a variety of different
parts of computer science
and other fields as
well use those notions.
So they're useful notions
beyond just in this course.
So I just want to--
a couple of administrative
things to touch on.
We are going to have
additional check-ins
today, as I mentioned to you.
We're going to start
counting participation-- not
correctness, just
participation--
in the live check-ins.
So with that, let us move
on to today's material.
As I mentioned,
we're going to be
showing how to convert
finite automata
to regular expressions.
And that's going to complete our
equivalence of finite automata
and regular expressions.
So just to recap what
we did last time,
we showed that if you
have a regular expression
and it describes some language,
then that language is regular.
So in other words,
we have a way of-- we
gave a way of converting regular
expressions to finite automata,
as kind of shown
in this diagram.
That's what we did last time.
Now we're going to
go the other way.
We're going to show
how to convert--
oh, and just a reminder in case
you're just getting yourself--
your memory to work,
maybe it'll help you just
to remember that we actually did
an example of that conversion.
We looked at this regular
expression, a union ab star.
And we actually worked through
the process of converting that.
Oops.
I need to make myself smaller
so you can see all that.
We went through the process
of converting a union ab
star as an example of that--
of-- made a mis--
[LAUGHS] OK.
Well, we went through the
process of actually doing
that conversion.
And now we're going to show how
to do it the other way around.
So we're going to invert that
and go backwards the other way.
So today's theorem is to
show that if a is regular,
namely, it's the language
of some finite automaton,
then you can convert it to a
regular expression which will
describe that same language.
So basically, we're going
to give a conversion
from finite automata
to regular expressions.
But before we do
that, we're going
to have to introduce
a new concept.
So we're not going to
be able to dive right
into that conversion.
We're going to have to do--
introduce a new model first,
which is going to
facilitate that conversion.
And that new model is called--
it's yet another kind of
finite automaton called
a Generalized
Nondeterministic Finite
Automaton, or a Generalized
NFA, or just simply a GNFA.
So this is yet another variant
of the finite automaton model.
And conceptually,
it's very simple.
It's similar to the NFAs.
I'll give you-- here's a
picture of a GNFA named G, G1.
Very similar to the NFAs.
But if you look at
it for a second,
you'll see that the transitions
have more complicated labels.
For the NFAs,
we're only allowing
just single symbols,
or the empty string,
to appear on the labels.
Now I'm actually allowing you
to put full regular expressions
on the labels for the automaton.
Now, we have to understand how
a GNFA processes its input.
And the way it works is not
complicated to understand.
When you're getting an
input string feeding--
when a GNFA is processing
an input string,
it starts at the start state,
just like you would imagine.
But now, to go
along a transition,
instead of reading just a single
symbol, or the empty string,
as in the case for the
nondeterministic machine,
it actually gets to read a
whole string at one step,
kind of, at one bite.
It can read an entire
string and go along
that transition arrow, provided
that chunk of the input
that it read is in
the regular expression
that that transition
has as its label.
So for example, this--
you can go from q1 to q2
in one step in this GNFA
by reading a, a,
b, b off the input.
So it reads all of those
four symbols all at once.
It just swoops them
up and then moves
from q1 to q2 in one step.
And then, when it's in q2 it
can read aab and move to q3.
And q3 happens,
there's nowhere to go.
So this is going to be a
nondeterministic machine.
There might be several different
ways of processing the input.
And if any one of them
gets to an accepting state
at the end of the input,
we say the GNFA accepts.
So it's similar to
nondeterministic--
to NFAs in the way the
acceptance criterion works.
So you could do an example.
But hopefully the concept of
how this works is reasonably--
you can at least buy
it, that it processes
the input in chunks at a time.
And those chunks
have to be described
by the regular expressions
on the transition arrows,
as it moves along
those transitions.
So what we're going to
do now is to convert
not DFAs to regular
expressions, we're
going to convert GNFAs
to regular expression.
That's even harder,
because GNFAs
are-- allow you to do all sorts
of other things besides just
ordinary DFAs.
So that's a harder job.
Why am I making my life harder?
Well, you'll see in
a minute that it's
going to actually turn out
to be helpful to be working
with a more powerful
model in the way
this construction
is going to work.
Now, before I dive in
and do the construction
from GNFAs to
regular expressions,
I'm going to make a simplifying
assumption about the GNFAs.
I'm going to put them
in a special form that's
going to make it easier
to do the conversion.
And that simpler form
is, first of all,
I'm going to assume the GNFA has
just a single accepting state.
And that accepting state is not
allowed to be the start state.
So it has to have just a
single accepting state.
I've already violated
that convenient assumption
in this GNFA, because I have
here two accepting states.
That's not what I want.
I want to have just one.
Well, the thing is, it's
easy to obtain just one,
just to modify the machine so
that I have just one by adding
a new accepting state
which is branched
to from the former accepting
states by empty transitions.
So I can always jump
from q2 to q4 at any time
without even reading any
input, just going along
this empty transition.
And then I declassify the former
accepting states as accepting.
And now I have here just
a single accepting state.
And because it's going to
be a new state that I added,
it won't be the start state.
And I have accomplished that
one aspect of my assumption
about the form of the GNFA.
But there's another thing
that I want to do, too.
I want to assume--
as you will see,
which is going to be
convenient in my
construction-- that we
will have transition arrows
going from every state
to every other state.
In fact, I want transition
arrows going from every state
even back to themselves.
I want there to be--
all possible transition
arrows should be present,
with two exceptions.
For the start state, there
should be only transition
arrows exiting the start state.
And for the accepting
state-- there's
just one now-- there should be
only transition arrows coming
into the start state.
So it's kind of what you would
imagine as being reasonable.
For the other states, which
are not accepting or starting,
there should be transition
arrows leaving and coming
from everywhere else.
But for the start
states, just leaving.
And from the accept
state, just coming in.
And you could easily modify
the machine to achieve that.
Let's just see how to
do that in one example.
So from-- notice
that from q3 to q2
there is no
transition right now.
And that's not good.
That's not what I want.
I want there to be a
transition from q3 to q2.
Well, I'll just add
that transition in.
But I'm going to label it
with the empty language
regular expression.
So that means, yeah,
the transition is there,
but you never can take it.
So it doesn't
change the language
that the machine is
going to be recognizing.
But it fulfills my assumption,
my convenient assumption,
that we have all of these
transition arrows being
present in the machine.
So anyway, I hope
you will buy it.
It's not going to be--
if you don't quite
get this, don't worry.
It's not totally
critical that you're
following all these little
adjustments and modifications
to the GNFA.
But it will be helpful
to understand what GNFAs
themselves-- how they work.
So as I mentioned,
we can easily modify
GNFA to have the special form
that we're assuming here.
So now we're going to jump in
and start doing the conversion.
So we're going to
have a lemma, which
is like a theorem that really
is just of local interest here.
It's not a general
interest theorem.
It's going to be
relevant just to GNFA,
which are really just defined
to help us do this conversion.
They really don't have any
other independent value.
So every-- you want to
show that every GNFA has
an equivalent regular expression
R. That's really my goal.
And the way we're going to
prove that is by induction.
It's going to be by induction
on the number of states
of the GNFA.
Now, you really should be
familiar with induction
as one of the expectations
for being in this course.
But in case you're a little
shaky on it, don't worry.
I'm going to unpack
it as a procedure.
It's really just recursion.
You know, induction is just--
a proof that uses
induction is really
just a proof that calls itself.
It's just a proof that--
it's a recursive proof.
That's all it is.
So if you're comfortable
with recursion,
you'll be comfortable
with induction.
But anyway, I'm going to
describe this as a procedure.
So if you're a little shaky
on induction, don't worry.
So the basis is--
so first I'm going to
handle the case where
the GNFA has just two states.
Now, remember, I'm
assuming now my GNFAs
are in the special form.
So you can't even have
a GNFA with one state,
because it has to
have a start state
and it has to have
an accept state,
and they have to
not be the same.
So the smallest possible
GNFA to worry about
is a two-state GNFA.
Now, if we have a-- if we
happen to have a two-state GNFA,
it turns out to be
very easy to find
the equivalent
regular expression.
Why?
Because that two-state GNFA
can only look like this.
It can have a start state,
it can have an accept state,
and it can only have
a transition going
from the start to the accept
because no other transitions
are allowed.
It only has outgoing from the
start, only incoming from the--
to the accept.
And so there's only
one transition.
And it has a label with
a regular expression R.
So what do you think the
equivalent regular expression
is for this GNFA?
It's just simply the one that's
labeling that transition,
because that tells us when
I can go from the start
to the accept.
And there's nothing
else the machine can do.
It just makes one step,
which is to accept
its input if it's described
by that regular expression.
So therefore, the equivalent
regular expression
that we're looking for
is simply the label
on that single transition.
So two-stage GNFAs are easy.
But what if-- what happens
if you have more states?
Then you're going to actually
have to do some work.
So we call that
the induction step.
That's when we have
more than two states.
And what that-- the way the
induction works is we're
going to assume we
already know how
to do it for k minus 1 states.
And we're going to
use that knowledge
to show how to do
it for k states.
So in other words,
we already know
how to do it for two states.
I'm going to use
that fact to show
how to do it for three states,
and then use the fact that I
can do it for three states
to show how to do it for four
states, and so on, and so on.
And the idea for how to do
that is actually pretty easy
to grasp.
What we're going to do is,
if we have a k state GNFA
that we want to
convert, we're going
to change that k state GNFA
to a k minus 1 state GNFA
and then use our assumption
that we already know how
to do the k minus 1 state GNFA.
So in terms of a picture,
I'm going to take a k state--
to prove that I can
always convert k state
GNFAs to regular
expressions, I'm
going to show how to convert the
k state one into an equivalent
k minus 1 state GNFA.
And then, if you just like to
think of this procedurally,
the k minus 1 gets
converted to a k minus 2,
gets converted to a k minus
3, and so on, and so on,
until I get down to two, which
then I know how to do directly.
So the whole name
of the game here
is figuring out how
to convert a GNFA that
has k states into another one
that has one fewer state that
does the same language.
So you have to hold
that in your head.
I mean, I wish I had more
blackboard space here,
but it's very limited here.
So you have to
remember what we're
going to be doing
on the next slide,
because that's going to
finish the job for us.
As long as I can show in
general how to convert a K,
state GNFA to a GNFA
that has one fewer state
but it still does
the same language,
I'm good, because then
I can keep iterating
that till I get down to two.
So here is-- this is the
guts of the argument.
So I have my k state machine.
Here's my start state.
Here's my accept state.
Here's my k minus 1
state, that machine
that I'm going to
be building for you.
It's actually going to be--
look almost exactly the same.
I'm just going to remove one
state from the bigger machine.
So I'm going to pick any
state which is not the start
state or the accept state.
Here it is pictured here.
I mean, all of the states
of the k state machine
are going to appear in the
k minus 1 state machine
except for one state that
I'm going to rip out.
That's the state x.
It's now here as a ghost.
It's been removed.
It's not there anymore.
But I'm just helping
you to remember
that it used to be there
by showing this shadow.
But it's a--
I have taken my original
machine that had k states
and basically just
ripped out a state.
And now I have one fewer state.
So the good news is that
I now have a machine
with k minus 1 states.
That's what I want.
But the bad news
is that it doesn't
do the same language anymore.
I broke the machine by rip--
if you're just going to rip
out a state, who knows what
the new machine is going to do.
It's going to be probably
not the same as what
the original machine did.
So what I need to do,
then, is repair the damage.
I've got to fix the damage
that I caused by removing x.
And whatever role x was playing
in the original machine,
I've got to make sure that
the new machine that I have,
which doesn't have x anymore,
can still do the same things
that the original machine did.
And so the way I'm
going to do that is
look at all of the paths that
could go through x and make
sure that they are still
present even though I
don't have x anymore.
And the way I'm going to do
that is, I'm going to take--
consider a part of a
path that might use x.
So it starts-- let's pick
two states, qi and qj,
in the machine
that had k states.
Let me just see here--
I don't know if this--
OK.
We have-- if we have--
we'll pick two states, qi and
qj, in the original machine.
Now, qi might have
the possibility
of going to state x.
And then x might
have a self loop.
And then it might go to qj.
The new machine doesn't
have an x anymore.
The way I'm going to fix that
is by replacing the label that
goes directly from i to
j with a new label that
adds in all of the things
I lost when I removed x.
That's the whole idea here.
So here is qi to qj, but
there's no x anymore.
How could I get from qi to qj?
What were the inputs that
could have brought us
from qi to qj via x?
Well, they would have
been an input that
read a string described by r1.
I might have self-looked
at x a few times,
so I might have read
several strings that
are described by r2.
And then I would
have read a string
that was described by r3.
And now I'm at qj.
So the new label that I'm
going to place over here
is going to be the strings
that I get from reading r1--
reading a string that's
described by r1, then
multiple copies of strings--
multiple strings
that are possibly
describing r2, which
is the same as r2 star.
Oh, and then
multiples-- and then
a string that could
be described by r3.
So that is a new addition
to the transition
that takes me from qi to qj.
Of course, I need to
include the things that
would have taken me from qi
to qj in the first place.
So I'm also unioning
in r4, which
is the direct
route from qi to qj
that did not transit through x.
So by making that new
regular expression
on the qi to qj transition,
I have compensated
for the loss of x for paths that
go from qi to x and then out to
qj.
Now, what I need to do
is to do that same thing
for every pair qi and qj that
are in the original machine.
And so if I do that for
every possible pair,
I'll be modifying all
of the transitions
in the new machine in a way that
compensates for the loss of x.
And now the new machine has
been repaired from the damage
that I caused by removing x.
And it does the same language.
It's the kind of thing you need
to think a little bit about.
I understand.
But at least
hopefully, the spirit
of what I just described
to you comes through,
that we're going
to convert this k--
machine with k states to
one with k minus 1 states
by removing a state and
repairing the damage.
And now it does
the same language.
And then I can
remove another state
and do the same thing
over and over again
until I get down to two states.
So that's the idea.
And that really
completes the proof.
That shows that I can
convert every GNFA
to a regular expression.
And that really is the
end of the story for this.
And thus I claim that DFAs,
now, and regular expressions
are equivalent.
So let me-- going to give you
a little check-in here on this,
really just to see,
high-level, if you're following
what's going on.
So just take a look.
So we just showed how to convert
GNFAs to regular expression.
But we really wanted to convert
DFAs to regular expressions.
So how do we go from GNFA--
converting GNFAs
to converting DFAs?
Because they're not
the same, obviously.
Right?
So how do we finish that?
So there are three choices here.
First, we have to show how to
convert DFAs to GNFAs, maybe?
Or show how to
convert GNFAs to DFAs?
Or maybe we're already done?
So maybe I better launch that
poll while you're reading that.
And there you go.
Hopefully you can-- all right.
Why don't I end this?
It's a little
worrisome, because I
would say we have a plurality
who got the right answer,
but not a majority.
So let us share the results.
I think-- so I sense not
all of you are with me.
But you're going to have to--
either that or you're
playing-- you're reading
your email while we're talking.
I'm not sure.
But whatever it is, you need to
think a little bit about what's
going on here, because
the reason why we are done
is because DFAs are
a kind of GNFAs.
They're just-- they
have a very simple kind
of regular expression
on each transition.
They just have the
regular expression
which is just a single symbol.
So all DFAs are
automatically GNFAs.
So if I can convert GNFAs, I
can certainly convert DFAs,
because GNFAs include the DFAs.
I'm done.
It really was-- number C
was the correct answer.
So good thing we're not [LAUGHS]
counting correctness here.
So participation is good enough.
But I do think you need
to think about what's
going on and making sure
that you're following along.
So anyway, that's a--
we'll carry on here.
But it makes me a
little concerned.
So let us now move on.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about non-regular languages.
So somebody's asking,
don't we have to still make
the DFAs into the special type?
Yes, we do have to make
them to the special type.
But we already showed
how to make GNFAs
into the special type.
And DFA-- that is going
to apply to DFAs as well.
They'll become GNFAs.
You can add the extra starts--
add a new start state,
add a new accept state,
add in all the
transitions with-- which
you didn't have before with
the empty language label,
and you'll have a
GNFA from a DFA.
But that applies to GNFAs as--
in general.
So it's nothing special
about DFAs there.
Anyway, I think you
need to chew on that.
And hopefully you're-- you'll
be following going forward.
Anyway, let us look now at
non-- proving non-regularity.
So we're finished with
our goal of showing
that regular languages-- that
the regular languages can
either come from DFAs or
from regular expressions.
Those are the same in terms
of-- from the perspective
of our course, they're
interchangeable.
So now, as we
mentioned, there are
going to be some languages
which are not regular,
which can't be done by DFAs.
They're actually-- DFAs
are actually pretty
weak as a computational model.
And so there's all sorts of very
simple things that they cannot
do--
though there are some fairly
complicated things that they
can do, surprisingly enough.
But anyway, there are some
simple things they can't do.
And so we have to develop
a method for showing
that a language is not regular.
And that's going to be
useful for your homework
and in general for
just understanding
the power of DFAs.
So how do we show a
language is not regular?
So remember, if you want to
show a language is regular,
basically what you need
to do is give a DFA.
Or you can use the
closure properties.
That's another way of showing
a language is regular.
But underneath that, it's
basically constructing DFAs.
To show a language
is not regular you
have to give a proof.
Generally it's not
a construction,
it's a proof that there is
no DFA or that whatever--
that it's just going to be
impossible to make a DFA.
And we have to develop a method.
What is that proof method?
Now, there is a tempting--
you know, I've taught
this course many times,
and there's a tempting
approach that many people have.
It's not only going to
apply for finite automata,
but for other things too.
And believe me, it's not
only people in this class,
it's for people
out there in the--
who are trying to think about
computation in general--
which is to say, well,
I have some language.
I'm trying to figure out
if it's regular or not.
And so I thought really
hard how to make a DFA,
and I couldn't find one.
Therefore, it's not regular.
That's not a proof.
Just because you
couldn't find a DFA
doesn't mean there is no DFA.
You need to prove that
the language is not
regular using some method.
So I'm going to give
you an example where
that kind of approach
can lead you wrong.
And that is-- I'll give
two examples of languages
where you might try to prove
they're regular or not,
and you could be in
trouble if you just follow
that kind of informal approach.
So if you take the language B,
where these are strings-- well,
let's assume our alphabet
is zeros and ones.
B is the language
of all strings that
have an equal number
of zeros and ones.
So you want to know,
if I have 1,000 zeros,
I need to have 1,000 ones.
So basically, the way
you test that, you'd
have to count up
the number of zeros,
count up the number of ones,
and see if those two counts are
the same.
And that's going to be really
tough to make a DFA do,
because how are you
going to remember such--
that really big number
of zeros that-- the DFA
might have 50 states.
But you might need to count
up to 100 or a million
to figure out-- to count up
how many zeros you've seen.
And it seems really hard to be
able to do that kind of a count
when you only have 50 states.
So whatever number
of states you have,
it seems hard to count when
you have a finite automaton.
So the intuition
is, it's not regular
because a finite
automaton can't count.
Which, in this case, you
can convert that intuition
into a real proof.
I would say it's not
a real proof yet,
but it can be made
into a real proof.
But compare that case
with another language,
which I'll call C, which,
instead of looking at its input
to see whether it has an equal
number of zeros and ones,
I'm going to look at the input
and look at the substrings
of 01s and 10s--
those two substrings-- and count
the number of occurrences of 01
as a substring and the
number of occurrences of 10
as a substring.
Just to make sure
you're understanding,
let's look at some example--
two examples.
So the string 0101 is
not going to be in C,
because if you count up the
number of 01s and the number
of 10s, not the same.
So I'm even going to help you
here, if you can see that.
The number of 01s is two.
But there's only a
single occurrence of 10.
So those are-- those two
counts are different.
And so that's why this
input string is not in C.
Compare that with
the string 0110.
Now, if you count up the
number of 01 and 10 substrings,
you're going to
get the same value,
because here we have a
single 01 and a single 10.
And so now the two counts of
those number of substrings
are the same.
And so that's where you're in C.
Now my question is, is
C a regular language?
Well, it looks like it shouldn't
be regular for the same reason
that B isn't regular-- because
you have to count up two
quantities and compare them.
OK?
So now, so if we--
so that's our
intuition, that you just
can't do it for the--
with a finite automaton,
because you have to do the same
kind of counting that you would
have had to do for language
B. But here you'll be--
you would be wrong, because
C, in fact, is regular.
It has a much
simpler description
than the one I gave over
here at the beginning.
The very same language,
C, can be described
in a much, much simpler way.
I'm not going to
tell you what it is.
You can mull that over.
You can try some examples
to figure it out.
But it has a much
simpler description.
It's not a totally
trivial description.
There is some content there.
But there is-- it
is the kind of thing
that a finite automaton can do.
It wouldn't do the
counting this way.
So the moral is--
the punch line is
that sometimes the intuition
works, but it can also
be wrong.
And so the moral
of the story is,
you need to give a proof when
you're doing things like that.
So what we're going to do
next, in the second half
of the lecture, is to
give a method for proving
languages are not regular.
And again, you're going to need
to use that on your homework.
So I hope you get it.
But first of all--
did I-- never stopped
sharing that poll.
Forgive me.
And so with that,
I think we'll take
our little requested break.
And-- for five minutes.
And we'll be back
in five minutes.
So, break time.
We are done here.
And proving languages
not regular.
The way we're going to prove
languages are not regular
is by introducing a method
called the pumping lemma.
And the overarching plan
at the pumping lemma,
without getting into the
specifics of it, is to say--
show that--
that lemma says all
regular languages
have a certain property,
which we will describe.
And so to show a
language is not regular
you simply show the language
doesn't have that property,
because all regular languages
have to have that property.
And so by showing a language
fails to have the property,
it could not be regular.
That's the plan.
Now, the property itself
is a little complicated
to describe, but not too bad.
I'll try to unpack it for you.
But first, let's look at
the statement of the lemma,
which says that whenever you
have a regular language--
let's call it A. So for
every regular language A
there's always a special
value called the pump--
a number.
p, we'll call it-- called
the pumping length.
It's a special number.
And it's-- and that length tells
you that whenever a string is
in that language and it's
longer than that length,
then something special happens.
You can take that string
and you can modify it,
and you still stay
in the language.
So anything that's longer
than that special length
can be modified
in a certain way,
and you still stay
in the language.
So let's look at the actual
statement of the lemma.
So there is a number
p such that if s
is a string in the language and
it's longer than p, or at least
of length p, then you can
take s and you can cut it up
into three pieces--
x, y, and z--
so that's just breaking
s into three pieces--
where you can take that middle
piece, repeat it as many times
as you like, and you still
stay in the language.
That's the-- what the
pumping lemma is saying.
And there's a bunch of
other conditions here too.
But the spirit of
the pumping lemma
says, whenever you have a
regular language there's
some cutoff such
that all strings
longer than that cutoff
can be what we call pumped.
You can take that string,
you can find a section
somewhere in the
middle of that string
or somewhere-- you cut
it up in three pieces,
you take that center piece,
and you can repeat it.
You can pump it up.
And by repeating that string
and repeating that piece,
the string gets
longer and longer.
But you still stay
in the language.
That's the special property
that all regular languages have.
So in an informal
way-- and we'll do--
I'll try to help you get
the feeling for this.
Informally, it says that if
you have a regular language,
then every long string--
so a long is by--
informal way of saying
bigger than this value p.
Every long string in the
language can be pumped.
And this result still
stays in the language.
And by "pumped" means I can cut
the string into three pieces
and repeat that middle piece
as many times as I want.
That's what I mean
by pumping a string.
So we'll do some
examples in a second.
But first we're going to
see how to prove this.
And hopefully, that'll give
you some feeling, also,
for why it's true.
So-- and actually, maybe before
I actually jump into the proof,
let me-- let's look at
these three conditions
here just to understand it a
little bit more thoroughly.
So condition one kind of says
what I just was telling you.
I can break s into
three pieces--
x, y, z-- such that if
I take x y to the i z--
so that's repeating y
as many times as I want.
So here's y to the i defined,
if that's helpful to you--
it's just y--
i copies of y.
So I can take x y
to the i z, and I
remain in the language
for every value of i--
even i equals 0,
which means we're just
removing y, which is sometimes
actually a useful thing to do.
But let's not get
ahead of ourselves.
So if-- you know, I can cut s--
I'm guaranteed to be able
to cut s up into x, y, z
so that the string xyyy is still
in the language, or xyyyyy--
it's still in the language.
That's going to be guaranteed
for every regular language.
That's a feature that's
going to be true.
And furthermore--
and this is going
to be turning out to
be-- it's not really
part of the core idea
of the pumping lemma,
but it actually turns out to
be very helpful in applying
the pumping lemma.
You can always cut
it up in such a way
that the first two pieces are
not longer than that value p.
So this-- it restricts on the
ways you can cut the thing up.
And that actually turns
out to be very helpful.
But let's first just look
at the proof of this,
giving a little bit
the high-level picture.
So my job is to show, if I
have a string in my language--
let's say it's a--
think of it as a long
string, really long.
So its length is more than p.
But I think intuitively,
it's just a very long string.
And I'm going to feed that
string into the machine
and watch what happens.
Something special happens
when I feed the string
and I look at how the machine
proceeds on that string,
because s is so long
that as I wander around
inside the machine
I have to end up
coming back to the same
place more than once.
It's like if you
have a small park
and you go for a long walk.
You're going to end up
coming back to where you've--
what you've already seen.
You just can't keep
on seeing new stuff
when you have a more small
area of space to explore.
So we're guaranteed
that M is going
to end up repeating some
state when it's reading s
because s is so long.
So in terms--
pictorially, if you
imagine here this wiggly line
is describing the path that M
follows when it's
reading s, it ends up
coming back to that
state qj more than once.
So it comes back
here, cycles around,
comes back again before
it ends up accepting.
We know it ends up
accepting because we're
assuming we have a string
that's in the language.
So we picked s in the language.
So it has to be accepted by
M. But the important thing
is that it repeats a state.
Now, how does that
tell me I can cut s up
into those three pieces?
Well, I'm going to get
those three pieces here.
First of all, let's observe
that here is processing--
as processing s.
Here is the-- written
right on top of the string,
that state repetition
occurring, qj, more than once.
And now, if I look
inside the machine,
the part of s that took me
to qj I'm going to call x.
The part that took
me from qj back
to itself I'm going to call y.
And the part that took
qj to the accept state
I'm going to call z.
And I'm going to
mark those off in s.
And that gives me the way to
cut s up into three pieces.
Now, if you're
appreciating what's
going on inside the
machine, you will
see why M will also
accept the string xyyz--
because every time-- once you're
at qj, if you go around once,
you come back to qj.
And then if you go again,
you'll come back to qj.
And as many times as
you keep seeing that y,
you're just going to
keep coming back to qj.
So it doesn't matter
how many y's you have.
You're going to still--
if you follow it
by z, which is what
you will do-- you'll
end up accepting this string.
And that's really the proof.
I mean, you have to
do a little bit more
here just to understand--
I should have
mentioned why I want
to forbid y being
the empty string,
because if y's the empty
string it's not interesting.
It doesn't change--
repeating it doesn't actually
change anything.
So I have to make
sure it's not empty.
But anyway, that's
a detail here.
If you look at the
string xyyz, that's
still going to be accepted.
So that's the proof
of the pumping lemma.
So let's have a little
check-in related to that.
This is not going to be--
again, not super hard.
But more just a curiosity.
So the pumping lemma depends on
the fact that if M has p states
and it runs for
more than p steps,
then it's going to
enter some state twice.
So you may have
seen that before.
It actually has a name which
some of you may have seen.
So let's see how to
just get a poll here.
And I hope not too many of
you are going to pick C,
as it's-- some of you are.
[LAUGHS] Oh well.
Yes, I think this
one most of you are--
you've seen this before.
This is-- I think you
pretty much all got it.
This is what's known as
the Pigeonhole Principle.
So here, sharing the
results, obviously I
was having a little
fun with this.
I'm sure some of you were
having fun back at me.
That's OK.
So let's continue on.
Let's see how to use the pumping
lemma to prove a language
is not regular.
So I put the pumping
lemma up here
just so you can remember
the statement of it.
So let's take the language
D, which is the language 0
to the k 1 to the k for any k.
So that's some number
of zeros followed
by an equal number of ones.
We're going to prove
that language is not
regular by using
the pumping lemma.
And this is going to be
just an ironclad proof.
It's not going to say, well,
I couldn't think of how to--
I couldn't think of how to
find it a finite automaton.
This is going to be--
this is going to
really be a proof.
So we want to show
that D is not regular.
And we're going to give--
these things always go as
a proof by contradiction.
So proof by contradiction--
hopefully as a reminder to you,
the way that works
is you're going
to assume the opposite of
what you're trying to prove.
And then from that, something
crazy is going to happen,
something you know is
obviously false or wrong.
And so therefore
your assumption,
which is the opposite of what
you were trying to prove,
had to be wrong.
And so therefore, the thing
you're trying to prove
has to be right.
That's the essence of what's
called proof by contradiction.
So first of all,
we're going to assume,
to get our contradiction,
that D is regular,
which is what we're trying
to show is not the case.
Now, if D is regular, then we
can apply the pumping lemma up
above here, which gives us
that pumping length p, which
says that any string
longer than p can be pumped
and you stay in the language.
That's what the pumping
lemma tells you.
So let's pick the string
s, which is the string
0 to the p 1 to the p.
Here's sort of a picture
of s off on the side here.
So a bunch of zeros followed
by an equal number of ones.
And that string is in D because
D is strings of that form.
And it's longer than p.
Obviously, it's of length 2p.
So the pumping lemma
tells us there's
a way to cut it up satisfying
those three conditions.
So how in the world could
we possibly cut s up?
Well, remember the
three conditions.
And especially condition 3 is
going to come in handy here.
Say that you can cut s
up into three pieces--
x, y, and z--
where the first two pieces lie
in the first p symbols of s
at most p long.
So x and y together
are not very big.
They don't extend beyond
the first half of x--
first half of s.
And in particular,
they're all zeros.
x and y are going to be
all zeros. z is going
to perhaps have
some zeros and will
have the rest of the
ones-- will have the ones.
Now, the pumping lemma says
that if you cut it up that way,
you can repeat y as
many times as you like
and you stay in the language.
But that's obviously false,
because if you repeat y--
which now has only zeros--
you're going to
have too many zeros.
And so the resulting
string is no longer
going to be of the form
0 to the k 1 to the k.
It's going to be lots of zeros
followed by not so many ones.
That's not in the language.
And that violates what
the pumping lemma tells
you is supposed to happen.
And that's a contradiction.
So therefore, our assumption
that D is regular is false.
And so we conclude
that D is not regular.
So that's a fairly simple one.
I thought I would do
another couple of examples,
because you have
this on your homework
and I thought it
might be helpful.
So here's the second one--
slightly harder, but not
too much.
Let's take the
language F, which is--
looks like the string's ww.
These are strings that--
two copies of the same string.
For any string that
might be in sigma star,
so for any string
at all, I'm going
to have two copies
of that string.
And so F is those strings
which can be-- which are just
two copies of the same string.
We're going to show
that F is not regular.
These things always
go the same way.
It's the same pattern.
You prove by contradiction.
So you assume for
contradiction that--
oh, D. That's bad.
That was copied
from my other slide.
That's wrong.
Let's see if I can actually
make this work here.
Good.
Assume for contradiction
that F is regular.
The pumping lemma
gives F as above.
And so now we need
to choose a string s
that's in F to do the pumping
and show that the pumping lemma
is going to fail.
You're going to pump
and you're going
to get something which is not
in the language, which is--
shows that the pump--
something has gone wrong.
But which s to choose?
And sometimes that's
where the creativity
in applying the
pumping lemma comes in,
because you have
to figure out which
is the right string
you're going to pump on.
So you might try the string--
well, 0 to the p 0 to the p.
That's certainly in F. It's
two copies of the same string.
Here it is.
I've written lots
of zeros followed
by the same number of zeros.
The problem is, if
you use that string,
it actually is a string
that you can pump.
You can break that string
up into three pieces.
And then, if you let
y be the string 00--
actually, you have to
be a little careful.
The string just 0 doesn't
work, because there's
an evenness-oddness
phenomenon going here.
So you might want to
just think about that.
But if you let y
be the string 00,
then if you have the string xy--
x any number of y's--
it's still just going
to be a bunch of zeros.
And you're going to be able to
see that that string is still
in the language.
So you haven't learned anything.
If the pumping lemma
works and you're
satisfying the pumping lemma,
you haven't learned anything.
So what you need to find
is some other string.
That was a bad choice for s.
Find a different string.
So here's a different choice,
0 to the p 1 0 to the p 1.
So that's two copies
of the same string.
And you're going to
show it can't be--
we're going to show
it can't be pumped.
So here's a picture
of that string here.
So zeros followed by
1, zeros followed by 1.
And now it's a very similar
to the first argument.
If you cut it into three
pieces in such a way
that it satisfies
the conditions,
the first two pieces are
going to be residing only
among the zeros.
And so therefore,
when you repeat a y
you're no longer going to have
two copies of the same string.
And so it won't be
in the language.
So therefore, you've got a
contradiction and F is not
regular.
So you have to play with the
pumping lemma a little bit.
If you haven't seen that
before it's going to be--
it takes a little
getting used to.
But you have a few
homework questions
that need to be solved
using the pumping lemma.
So now, let's look at--
lastly, there is another
method that can come in,
which is combining
closure properties
with the pumping lemma.
So closure properties
sometimes help you.
So let's look at the language
B, which is actually,
we saw earlier in
the lecture, where
we have an equal number
of zeros and ones.
Now, we could prove
that directly,
using the pumping lemma,
as not being regular.
But it's actually even easier.
What we're going to prove--
that-- we're going to
prove that it's not
regular in a different way.
First we're going to assume for
contradiction, as we often do,
that it is regular.
And now we're going to use
something-- we're going
to use some other knowledge.
We're not going to use
the pumping lemma here
because we're going
to take advantage
of an earlier case where
we used the pumping lemma.
And so now we know
that the string--
the language 0 star 1 star
is a regular language,
because it's described
by a regular expression.
If you take the B, which is
the equal numbers of zeros
and ones, and you intersect
it with 0 star 1 star,
that's going to be
a regular language
if B was regular, using
closure under intersection.
But this language B
intersect 0 star 1 star
is the language of equal
numbers of zeros and ones
where the zeros come first.
And that's the
language D that we
showed two slides back, that we
already know can't be regular.
So that intersection
cannot be regular.
And so it violates
the closure property.
And again, we get
a contradiction.
So that's a different way of
sometimes making a shortcut
to prove a language
is not regular.
So we have-- in our
last 10 minutes or so,
we're going to
shift gears totally,
in an entirely different
way, and consider
a new model of computation
which is more powerful,
that can actually
do things that we
can't do with finite automata.
And these are called
context-free grammars.
So this is really
just an introduction.
We're going to spend all
of next lecture looking
at context-free grammars and
their associated languages.
But let's just do--
get a preview.
So a context-free
grammar looks like this.
You have a bunch of these--
what we call substitution
rules, or rules,
sometimes, which just
look like a symbol,
arrow, a string of symbols.
That's what a
context-free grammar
looks like at a high level.
Let's define some terms.
So a rule, as I
just described, is
going to be-- look-- it's
going to be a symbol, which
we're going to call a variable.
And that's going to have an
arrow to a string of other--
possibly, other variables
and symbols called terminals.
So a variable is a symbol that
appears on the left-hand side
of a rule.
Anything that appears
on the left-hand side
is going to be considered
to be a variable.
So S and R are both variables.
Now, other symbols that
appear in the grammar which
don't appear in the
left-hand side--
those are going to
be called terminals.
So here, 0 and 1 are terminals.
Now, you may think that
empty string should also be
a terminal .
But that's not a symbol.
Empty string is a string.
It's just a string of length 0.
So I'm not considering empty
string to be a terminal.
So-- and then there's going
to be a special variable which
is going to be considered the
starting variable, just like we
had a starting state.
And that's typically going to be
written as the top-left symbol.
So this symbol s, here, is
going to be the starting symbol.
And grammars can be used to
define languages and to--
well, to generate strings
and to define languages.
So first of all, let's
see how a grammar,
using this as an illustration,
can generate strings.
Actually, just to emphasize
this terminology here,
in this particular example
we had three rules.
The two variables were R and S.
The two terminals were 0 and 1.
And the start variable was
this top left-hand symbol,
as I mentioned-- the S.
So grammars generate strings.
The way they do is you
follow a certain procedure,
which is really pretty simple.
You write down, first of
all, the start variable.
And I'll do an
example in a second.
You write down the
start variable.
And then you take a look
what you've written down.
And if it has any
variables in it,
you can apply one of the
corresponding right-hand sides
of a rule as a substitution
for that variable.
And so-- like, for example,
if you have an S in the thing
you've written down, you can
substitute for that S a 0S1.
Or you could substitute for that
S an R. Or if you have an R,
you can substitute for
the S an empty string.
So you're just going to keep on
doing that substitutions over
and over again until there
are no variables left,
so there's nothing
left to substitute.
Only terminals remain.
At that point,
you have generated
a string in the language.
So the language, then,
is the collection
of all generated strings.
Let's do an example.
Here's an example of G1
generating some string.
So as I mentioned,
first of all, you're
going to write down
the start variable.
And I'm just going to illustrate
this in two parallel tracks
here.
On the left side
I'm going to show
you the tree of substitutions.
And on the right side
I'm going to show you
the resulting string
that you get by applying
those substitutions.
So over here I'm
going to substitute
for S the string 0S1.
So on the right-hand
side I just have 0S1,
because that's what
I substituted for S.
But you'll see it's not
going to-- it's going to look
a little different in a second.
Here, I'm going to-- again
I still have a variable.
So I'm going to
substitute for S 0S1.
Now I have the string--
resulting string 00S11,
because I've substituted 0S1
for the previous S, but the 0
and 1 stick around from before.
They don't go anywhere.
So I have, at this point, 00S11.
Now I'm going to take
a different choice.
I'm going to substitute for S--
I could have gone either way.
This would have something--
almost like non-determinism
here, because you have a choice.
I'm going to substitute for S--
instead of 0S1 I'm
going to substitute R,
because that's also legitimate
in terms of the rules.
And so now I'm
going to have 00R11.
And now R-- there's
no choices here.
R can only be substituted
for by an empty string.
So I get to R becomes
just empty string.
And in terms of the
string generated,
empty string doesn't
add anything.
It just really is--
it's a nothing.
So I get the string 0011.
And this is a string
just of terminal symbols.
And so that is a string in the
language of the grammar G1.
And if you think about
it, G1's language
is that language
that we saw before,
which I think we called D--
0 to the k 1 to the k for k
greater than or equal to 0.
So this is an example of a
language that a context-free
grammar can do but a
finite automaton cannot do.
So that is our little
introduction to--
oops.
There's one more check-in here.
Oh, yeah.
So I'm asking you to
actually look at--
let me get myself
out of this picture
so you don't see
me blocking things.
And we will do
one last check-in.
Make sure you're staying
around for the whole thing.
Now there could be several
of these strings that
are in the language.
You have to click them
all-- all of the ones
that you have found that are
in the language of this grammar
that can be generated by grammar
G2, you have to click those.
I'll give you a little
bit more time on this one
to see which ones
G2 can generate.
I'll give you a hint.
It's more than one, but not all.
So I see you're making
some progress here.
Interesting.
So please-- we're going to
wrap this up very quickly.
You can-- somebody's telling
me you can't unclick.
Thank you.
Good to know.
Still, things are
coming in here.
So let's not-- we're running
toward the end of the hour
here.
I don't want to go over.
So I'm going to end
it in five seconds.
Click away.
And don't forget, we're
not going to charge you
if you get it wrong.
Sharing results.
I don't know why it has
an orange one there,
because there are several
correct answers here.
So it's A, B, and D are correct.
You can get any of those.
It's really sort of two
copies of the language we
had before next to one another.
And so the only thing
you cannot get is 1010.
So I encourage you
to think about that.
And I will come to our
last side of today,
which is just a quick review.
I can put myself back.
So we showed how to convert
DFAs to regular expressions.
And the summary is that DFAs,
NFAs, GNFAs, even, and regular
expressions are all equivalent
in the class of languages
they can describe.
The second thing
we did was a method
for proving languages
not regular by using
the pumping lemma or
closure properties.
And lastly, we introduced
context-free grammars.
And we're going to see more
about those on Thursday.
So with that, I think
we're out of time.
And thank you for the
notes of appreciation.
And I will--
I think we're going to end here.
And see you on
Thursday, if not before.